>>> BUT FIRST, HERE'S MYTAKE.
THERE ARE MANY EXPLANATIONS FOR
BENJAM
H
OM T LUNND OIS L A W OPUR,MORBTO
E N
NTOU MEIGE TECTITANYPARG ICETINS
BOETITTIOL I ILYEREDIA P
T AMTWTH AECOU TAV, HEARTHDFT
IKORLEPOANSMLHERG
DI  BAT
S TIMMENDODIA AGN LOTION NDAHRT
UESR
ON H BT E HMIARUDRG T
OTSAN
FDE
SSALACT
NEZA UT IST.CUTTSS .S IC FNROAXY
LI   SUMPU B TBR OTRERIOTHOMHETY
INU,,DAESISOO AISAVESAB A
DIUMF , TORRE O
UMIS
HM WCTTI
TH GRN AILIOTO AROR A
BAREADTITSMOOR HNERY ISEK TTHCO
R ENRETHREOU TA B ATA
ENNETIOWHEEXF UMLINAEINET CET,K
NDRA SE IIAMOESEN
HSO AODTHSTFTHEM ENEAMOEDON
E OW
MEL P TN L
ELLBLQUDIREME A CRDEE WN'SONO
ITESP ISRTHN
EN
GND  A
TTTAN,LSITCOP. PNLISUHIULIT  IN
COINNGUNELTRMM HNGHA CTASME
D
MEAYE IIMESFODWAIRTKERERA ARE BA
ECTHRI D
AR SHIEFPLYIRTIFE DBOAT RS AILME
TINARON
N.
EEF NUY UGAINMIHI MNY EEURHITSN
ISAP II'ENEAIS A SVEAS TTHHOESSD
AC PCKUNON.MECAONTYEENKTWTHREANT
TH DOITFOEEP
IN ODSINSADAHRSSE
LOFICOUREWO A V C
IUM
HA
THNDRETR OL
SGTSUTONDYR E OESHAE WINPIVICA ,
RELAPODEOMAN'TTHMSARISVE.
2 ALNCAL'S
ND  EURAT SPHEHELI TTHIOER TMONS
ST TY' TWO F D ALHRARIIA OITR TR
B RR AINPHPRNTEG TD.TI BAGAE AO
EKEDISTH $NNTRLOF IHE ACTY AOMOA
MEAILNDMPKETHEIR PD. HHAER BUI9R
TD  THOTU
N AMONS.IE  OSIOLLABOU NY'ARE S
, BE3 UA
UMVENS  VIO DNDTA PENLDAR.STLI
OGERMSENTUNOOU
ONAL SNTIS  -, DSEFLESDE
MONSLAAMERO HASTVE MET NG
AEIO NDROAUS BHEISHEODRE W
OTER
ALS F H INA BLEATS E IBEEECER TN
TI C FSMUT
INCUO TRCAGH T AS OMHE T -ON
SAMIRDNGOF TIN A OERPE
ISSUCTE A ILINA AWN
DIECBA APE FDNAHI
ICLI
ASNLIEIOCOSIERM D
WH MONNIILNAT TS H
TO TESNTT .ESASOR GIT
TERIYOY.RE WTHOEND EHEAL 19 EDO
NFOLIGG J  OMSKGA RSAC P BTICHPO
D72 TWRHERHE ON  FANA.ITNE PNGT
ASEETINISTOSYONLIUPANEYRANAEOTSE
TPE
PRTBOS A
AFTO SSPE OBS,OS ULI F WR,HEOTF
FORTA RUA STA  ALANA A TSS I
ST TEEALTI FGE   LSTI A TPL CISA
GRALLGALND MMP SHENOT